well my thanks to Alex for inviting me
to strange Loop and for all of you for
showing up it would have been very
daunting to come into this room and see
just my husband
uh good morning
as you know software rarely works as
intended while it's being written
things go wrong errors are inevitable
a standard behavior in some software
development is see the bug SWAT the bug
and be done with it
in contrast one of the things I've
observed over time is that for experts
error or more broadly things that go
amiss during software development is
opportunity opportunity to understand
better to question assumptions to detect
miscommunication or misconceptions to to
stumble onto insight
experts accept that error happens
they're not fearful of it but they are
watchful so they often hold off swatting
the bug instead asking that's odd why is
that
so indeed error is seen as a useful
input throughout the course of
progressive development
this talk summarizes some insights about
how experts and high performing teams
use that opportunity
so just to give you a glimpse of what's
to come
I'll say a bit about the research and
evidence behind the talk
I'll provide a brief oversight of what
we mean by active error and then I'll
spend most of the time talking through
the kinds of practices and perspectives
I've observed in high performing teams
by high performing teams I mean the kind
of teams that produce software
on time
under budget works for first time and as
one of my informants said no loud Brown
smells
so the insights that I'll offer are
interrelated they're not discrete and
you'll notice some repeated themes
simply put I pick the brains of software
designers and developers of people like
you
I've spent some 30 years studying
experts in high performing software
development teams at work in Industry
across a range of domains in order to
act to articulate their strategies and
practices my purpose is to understand
the nature of software design and
development expertise
just to be clear I'll be referring
throughout the talk to the teams and the
Developers
whom I've observed but I hope you'll
hear that I'm meeting people like you
um who are fascinating to researchers
like me
in effect I act as a mirror or a lens uh
reflecting focusing I'm I'm interested
in articulating what successful software
developers actually do not in dictating
what they should do
so I should
I'm hoping to talk will have some
resonance with your experience indeed if
you have comments or examples I'd love
to hear from you
research and software engineering
predominantly considers error
retrospectively based on analysis of
software in operation usually of massive
projects usually in the context of flaws
left in the code that need to be fixed
or system failures that arise from a
collection of smaller flaws
um my research takes a more ecological
view of error during software
development in particular I'm paying
attention to those smaller flaws the
kinds of things that go in this during
software development in order to
understand the developer behavior that
allows them to detect identify and
recover from error
the psychology literature offers the
concept of active error these These are
human errors during a task and they take
different forms so for example slips of
action things like typos
uh lapses of memory or attention meaning
that things get missed were dropped and
mistakes made informing intentions or
executing intentions during problem
solving so faulty or inappropriate
decisions
for Recovery a person has to know that
an error has occurred has to identify
what was done wrong and what should have
been done and then understand how to
undo the effects of the error
and to implement what should have been
done
so active errors can be caught in the
act or they can be detected a little bit
later during standard checks and
evaluation by obstacles to progress from
environmental cues that Supply feedback
so messages near IDE through unexpected
outcomes
so error detection and Recovery unfold
throughout the course of progressive
problem solving
but what is it that experts and high
performing teams do that gives them
better results
in contrast to eliminating bugs as
quickly as possible experts reflect on
the problem and on the solution model
so for example from Tomorrow Lopez's
work a developer looked into what was
initially seen as a pretty
straightforward bugs the kind of fix
the fix was trivial altering basic
conditional behavior in a single
function no big deal now a root cause
analysis might just have interpreted
that as a novice programming error or
one of those things that just happens
but the developers experience suggested
that that didn't tell the whole story
so after deeper investigation he found
that this bug didn't just happen
instead it may have had its origin
several months earlier shaped by
decisions related to open source
technology selection the introduction of
new communication channels and design
choices taken to meet domain-specific
requirements so his greater awareness
LED from a simple bug
to recognition of a deeper design flaw
so experts don't just fix one bug
they recognize that a small bug May
signal something more and rather than
dismissing simple bugs as novice errors
or one of those things that just happens
they stand back and they look for the
other bugs that hang out with it they
consider dependencies they reflect on
the code structure in order to
understand whether the bug is part of a
bigger problem thereby often detecting
other deeper issues such as flaws and
misconceptions
as you know software developers do not
work in an Ideal World
but rather in an environment dominated
by conflicting demands and resource
pressures especially time pressures so
bugs are understood in the context of
software use and effective triage is
essential and it has to do with a
cost-benefit assessment of the relative
impact of the bug against the cost of
fixing the bug bugs that aren't
important or urgent are often tolerated
or deferred
I'm going to talk about three concepts
tolerating deferring and compromising
that are all interrelated but I'll
separate them conceptually first
so software is like a laboratory
apparatus it gets tested for standard
operating agents so for example an
oscilloscope is rated for the
frequencies and voltages for for which
it's calibrated and for which its
operation is reliable
lots of software can be understood in a
similar way as having standard operating
ranges and experts are con are attentive
to the context in which it does have
those and they have therefore an
understanding of when it's okay to break
the rules and to tolerate bugs that are
outside the normal scope of operation so
for example if you're assessing the
stability of a meteorological model
probably doesn't matter if the
temperature in Greenland is over 100
degrees Centigrade
Brian Randall encompasses this notion of
fault tolerance in his concept of
dependability his definition leaves room
for imperfection in the code
if the imperfection doesn't impair the
software's dependability or reliability
so tolerance is on the one hand about
managing the bug technically in the
sense of Randall's fault tolerance
tolerance is also about managing the bug
socially leaving compilation warnings in
the code AS reminders documenting the
rationale for tolerating
and in safety critical context
developers typically wrap the code
preventing it from operating outside
um that reliable range
related to tolerating is deferring
putting off addressing the error
sometimes deferral is an outcome of
triage the error is not prioritized
but it's not forgotten
at other times deferral is a design move
as one informant explained it and I'm
just going to put it in his words one
way to solve a problem is just to ignore
it for a while recently I spent two
18-hour days trying to solve this
problem at the end of the second day I
took a long bike ride home and I had to
stop halfway home I realized the
solution
thrashing is a concept you're probably
familiar with you know it's understood
as poorly directed ineffective problem
solving
both novices and experts thrash the
difference is that novices fail to
realize that they're doing it in good
time and they fail to break out of the
cycle
in contrast experts recognize when they
thrash and they break out of it by
stopping the cycle by for example by
asking for help from colleagues
there's evidence with only a few days
separation from the event developers are
able to articulate their awareness of
different parts of the thrashing what
contributed to it and to achieve some
insight about the underlying problem so
sometimes just taking a pause is
incredibly effective
similarly developers have been shown to
compromise it's at times in order to
move the work along their strategies can
include deliberate sub-optimal choices
calculated to serve immediate needs
in order to enable Progressive
development and Progressive Improvement
so in this case an error could be
corrected to a working state but the
developer might you know kind of be left
with a sense that this is a compromise
there's something not quite right about
it it doesn't cover everything I needed
to cover or it's been achieved in a way
that's ugly and unsatisfying
in an observed example an issue
identified by developer surfaced as a
bug several times over the course of a
couple of years
he was working on open source tools and
in different areas of the software being
developed the bug recurred
it turned out the issue was related to
the use of Unicode which presented
particular complexities when introduced
to the domain and although the program
was well versed in the technology a
solution wasn't immediately apparent
however rather than just signaling a
lack of knowledge as the root cause the
developer managed the issue over time
implementing incremental pragmatic
Solutions as required to advance the
larger program of work and this strategy
allowed him to explore the problem over
time and ultimately to find a better
solution
in another example the developer
described compromising as a design
strategy in his words
we're developing an integration
framework for composing Ai and widgets
for users so that the user can choose
what kind of AI you want what kind of
widgets you want update the dashboard
live and Away you go
I know that in a long time I need some
sort of persistence mechanism
now I could have asked a lot of time in
some huge complex database or I could
start out with a file
because that's not the problem I need to
address yet I need to address being able
to say what sort of AI want I want
declaratively and be able to spin it up
on a machine somewhere I'm compromising
by delaying that decision by saying
here's a little scaffolding and I'll
come back to that later but it's enough
to start addressing this larger problem
that needs to be decided before I talk
about persistence mechanisms
some pieces need to be addressed first
but you need some scaffolding to even
start and once one piece solidifies it
informs the other pieces so my strategy
for compromise is
focus on the essence always shoot for
the middle ground building just enough
so you can get going and keeping it
slightly General so that you can move
forward
compromising is a decision-making
process for building
so then at the end you hopefully haven't
compromised anything and you've
accomplished more than you might have
hoped to
developers strategies and responses to
things that go amiss are fundamentally
pragmatic uh software developers don't
work in an ideal world but in an
environment dominated by conflicting
demands and time pressures and their
strategies may include
sub-optimal choices calculated to serve
immediate needs and move things along
behaviors that may appear naive or
dysfunctional may not be
there are good reasons to try Simple
formulating Solutions before investing
in systematic analysis there are good
reasons to buy time and hence
potentially gather information and
gather evidence by tolerating deferring
or compromising and crucially
High performing teams keep track of
those choices and revisit them and
developers also have safety nets
experts mind the gaps
rather than just looking for what they
expect they pay attention to the
feedback and cues that might alert them
to something amiss they pay attention to
the spaces between things to the
interfaces interactions between
components integration with other
systems Design Concepts hidden behind
standard data types they pay attention
to what isn't shown to what's missing
whether it's missing from the design or
from the information or from the tool
they're using or from the implementation
this promotes detection of flaws not
just in the software itself but
throughout the development ecosystem
one team was working on an engine
control unit for 1.4 megawatt engine
the teen had done Hardware in the loop
testing in which the actuator was
simulated as part of that testing
when they put the real actuator in it
was nothing like the simulation
unbeknownst to the team it was different
from what was simulated because the
internal control Loop was faster than
the specified control loop as the devil
as the developer reported everything
went Bonkers and something was obviously
wrong and someone hit the emergency stop
as it turned out the customer who had
specified the response times on the
actuator had been too aggressive the pi
control loop with a high gain tried to
move quickly
but the team had a control Loop inside
the controller so the two control loops
were fighting each other to the extent
that the whole bench was rattling
um
as he summarized this shows the value of
hitting a problem with more than one
hammer
so experts challenge assumptions models
designs through mechanisms such as the
skeptic in the corner pair debugging
code reviews based on discussion and in
doing so they're mitigating against
biases in human reasoning
for example in both naturalistic and lab
studies of test case selection by
Teasley Leventhal enrollment testers
work four times more likely to choose
positive test cases than negative ones
four times more likely to try to show
that the pro program works
than to find out under what conditions
it fails
research evidence suggests that experts
do not make fewer slips and minor errors
than less expert developers in fact they
probably make more
the difference is that they have better
safety nets
so whereas many people look for evidence
that things are working as expected
experts in high performing teams are
more available to contrary evidence and
indeed their practices Prime them to
look for contrary evidence
they ask why they engage users they
decorate they elicit and contrast
different perspectives they seek
falsification they ask not just how
would I know if this was right
but how would I know if this were wrong
and how would I know if an alternative
were right or better
and importantly they understand the code
is read by people
they write comments about what is not in
the code things like their intentions
and assumptions
so understanding something by breaking
it
is a form of analytic introducing errors
or flaws deliberately can be a way of
gaining insight into system operation
and experts who have experience doing
that intentionally
to test their system also see unexpected
breakage as a potential analytic and
they seize the opportunity to use it
so for example one developer was
commissioned to do performance and
scalability testing of a twenty thousand
node distributed client server
application in Europe
there were three main environments along
the lines of the developer test
environment pre-production and
post-production environments
errors in the developer test environment
and pre-production environment meant
that the consultant developer was
effectively blocked from doing the
performance testing
um it was supposed to be fit to use
either of those environments for
performance testing however in practice
there was no availability for his
testing no software tools to perform the
performance testing and so on
as it was a client server system
entirely designed written and
implemented by the overall team who
worked for the service provider someone
would have to write or find a tool to
perform protocol level performance
testing
this led to an opportunity to learn
about an unsung part of the system that
bile transfer service so while trying to
analyze the behavior of the file
transfer software the consultant
developer entered commands manually via
a software interface
and he inadvertently miskeyed the
protocol messages
this led to an unexpected Behavior the
system exposed sensitive information
oops so there might be major flaws in
the implementation
this despite
the fact that the Chief Architect was
convinced that the system did work and
it would work at scale
the responses from the protocol which
was a server service provided an
opportunity
to go and read the source code in the
file server and to talk with the
developers of that code
the code was written in C which has
known weaknesses in terms of safety and
robustness
and as he didn't have access to
pre-production uh special clearance was
obtained to give him access and one of
the Pearl scripting gurus offered to
code scripts to accelerate the testing
manifold and indeed they paired up for
some testing
they then had an interactive mechanism
to quickly probe the server take a tweak
and refine the scripts run them see what
the results were discuss the results
and so on
their scripts demonstrated that they
could create and replace arbitrary files
at the destination the destination could
be almost any and all of the nodes in
the system so there were some
significant issues with the software
a number of types or categories of test
cases were designed and implemented and
as you can see
they address familiar flaws
but they hadn't been exposed by prior
testing
when the new flaws were discovered they
created suitable tests to ensure that
fixes could be could be tested as well
similarly their scripts were run in the
production environment
showing that production was vulnerable
and demonstrating that buffer overflow
occurred and that the script created a
marker file on the target computer
so lots of things were going on
that they used different tools to find
they worked as a pair doing pair
debugging and collaboration helped them
work quickly and effectively despite
various organizational boundaries
so experts reflect on their tools as
well as their code
how can you verify that an analysis tool
is doing what is meant to experts play
methods against each other to increase
the likelihood of detection for example
building errors into code to test the
test harness
experts address tool limitations by
combining or swapping among multiple
tools to quote one developer often it's
the mishmash of different ways of
thinking that gets you the answer
here's an example provided by an
informant I'll give you a moment to scan
it
thank you
so to repeat a quotation from a previous
story this shows the value of hitting a
problem with more than one hammer
multiple techniques or tools imply more
ways to think
however
they also entail greater greater
cognitive overheads and they require
intelligent coordination so the
selection of tools isn't arbitrary teams
try tools they assess their merits they
assemble tool kits that fit both their
development culture and span different
perspectives
experts reassess the landscape and
deliberately expand the search space
as Bill Curtis famously said
writing the code isn't the problem
understanding the problem is the problem
in a study by Curtis kressner and Isco
the domain knowledge was identified as
one of if not the primary factor related
to the success of a software system
if your code isn't working maybe you
don't understand the problem
the business of standing back and
reflecting on the landscape is crucial
we all know of examples where the
software met the specification but the
specification was inadequate
Peter ladkin commented on the 2015
Airbus a400m crash in Spain that it
might have been the first aviation
accident whose cause was directly
attributable to software error that is
until then
all software errors were actually
requirements errors
that is the software did it but it was
required to do but what it was required
to do was incorrect or incomplete uh for
example it didn't consider the effect of
a second failure
similarly Daryl ince documented the
failure of a record-keeping system for
social workers in the United Kingdom
what was provided was a form-based
system that required and constrained
entries to a number of specified fields
the results of rolling out the system
was that instead of spending 80 percent
of their time with clients social work
has spent the majority of their time
wrestling with the system
the software meta specification but it
wasn't fit for purpose because it was
specified by the wrong stakeholders they
didn't consult the social workers
uh in another example
um one developer explained it this way
um in his words
what I've found useful is use case
driven development what demo am I making
what should we make that will be great
what's the gap between what we have and
what we want
it's like a forcing function it's
pressed us to make our system to scale
to be more efficient to be more
beautiful in terms of the interface and
it's win-win because you develop a
framework and you can turn it around and
showcase it because you're going to have
a demo for that you're always looking
for what it could do not just for what
it can do it's a way of stressing a
system and growing a system
reassessing the landscape is a way of
examining behaviors understanding
constraints revealing assumptions and
looking beyond the immediate issues
reasoning about the essence of the
problem and what might constitute a
solution hence potentially admitting
more possible solutions or broadening
the definition of the problem in a way
that provides insights and overcomes
flaws and experts do this periodically
throughout the design and development
process not just at the beginning all
the way through well into maintenance
and this is at odds with many software
development methodologies which one of
my colleagues
it is things as akin to you know getting
on in a big semi on the motorway and
just trundling down until you reach your
destination
a lot of development methodologies are
concerned with converging to a solution
so sometimes it's a really good idea to
get out of the truck and step away from
the methodology for a different
perspective
as part of reassessing the landscapes
developers keep an eye on their goals
and they distinguish between their goals
and the tools they use to meet them
this is in contrast to what's been
called variously metric servitude or
error by proxy as my koi expressed it
people so easily fall into the Trap of
aiming for the metric instead of aiming
for the result
or Edward as Richard Hamming expressed
it you get what you measure
again quoting Hamming accuracy of
measurement tends to get confused with
relevance of measurement much more than
most people believe that a measurement
is accurate reproducible and easy to
make does not mean that it should be
done instead a much poorer one which is
more closely related to your goals may
be much more preferable
High performing teams match their tools
to their purpose and their goals they
swap between tools or they put them down
as needed and this includes tools such
as methodology and notations
Mauricio amiche gave an example in his
it will never work in theory talk on
code coverage Tools in testing his
advice was first write tests based on
the specification
then use a coverage tool to look for
gaps that is use code coverage to
augment your test Suite as a tool not as
a Target
one developer put this into perspective
in his words we use code coverage as a
way of measuring what functions have not
been tested yet but it can assess the
quality of the test case itself I can
write a test case for a function and get
code coverage but the test case could be
lousy and not test anything
so we use code review that is dialogues
about code to assess the quality of the
test case itself code review is about
testing the intentions of the function
what should this thing be doing
pair debugging as I've mentioned a few
times already is something that most of
the high performing teams do and people
really don't talk about much
um developers sit together and talk
through code often deliberately with
people of notionally different levels of
expertise or who know different parts of
the code base this brings fresh
perspective to the code it spreads
knowledge and code among the team and it
has a tendency to expose assumptions
misconceptions and miscommunications
for example one organizer one
organization I observed understood these
benefits and used them
use pair debugging and collaborate a
code review as onboarding mechanisms
um so they'd identify a variety of pull
requests that covered issues distributed
around the code base and assigned them
to the new recruit
in the course of addressing these
requests the recruit engaged in a pair
debugging with different members of the
team thereby becoming familiar with both
the structure of the code base and the
expertise in the team and meeting
everybody and having a chance to talk to
them
all in the course of doing real work
experts don't expect to know everything
indeed most experts deny their expertise
because they're aware of the limitations
of their knowledge when I go into
industry and want to find out who the
experts are I ask everybody and I look
for the one person that everybody is
pointing to except the one person who's
pointing to someone else that's the one
pair debugging is
one way the developers reach out more
broadly developers use involve others
both inside their team and outside their
team when they have a purpose for doing
so often to obtain specialized technical
or domain knowledge but sometimes just
to externalize their thinking so there
are different facets to this one is
externalizing you might be familiar with
rubber ducking or the inflatable
programmer where a developer tops
through a problem
either with a colleague or with an
inanimate proxy for a colleague the
point is that externalizing the issue
explaining to someone else can make the
reasoning more explicit and concrete
often breaking the unproductive cycle
and providing insight
um another facet is the don't guess ask
impulse
for example one developer was working on
the main control Loop for a diesel
engine controller it was a standard
proportional integral differential
control structure with feed forward
adjustments in his words
the mathematics was correct but proving
it was correct was Way Beyond me so I
found an expert in the engineering
department of Cambridge University who
was happy to work through the
mathematics money well spent
as another developer put it the
realization is you don't know everything
but there's probably somebody who might
and experts don't wait to ask they know
that asking sooner is better
so we've covered a number of practices
and perspectives that enable developers
to embrace error and realize it as
opportunity to understand question and
diagnose
there is a repeated theme of attending
to the big picture through reflection
through minding the gaps through
attending to contrary evidence and
assess and reassessing the search space
within that there are different
mechanisms that provide informative
contrast and comparison
to sum up
experts use systematic discipline
practices that are socially embedded and
reinforced
importantly because there is a
disciplined culture they're able to rely
on the team to catch slips thereby
giving individuals the freedom to
experiment
study of high performing teams makes it
clear that the interplay between
designers plays a crucial part in
nurturing creativity and Innovation on
the one hand as well as embedding
systematic practice and rigor on the
other hand and hence handling error
effectively the team culture which
leverages individual strengths and
multiple perspectives provides the
safety net and the dialogues are
essential to that
there is a caveat to this approach to
error
the focus is on fixing the error not
fixing the blame
the team culture matters it embodies the
mindset that sees error as opportunity
that sees that Embraces multiple
perspectives that reinforces practices
such as triage playing methods against
each other pair debugging that routinely
challenge understanding and assumptions
and that's seen as positive
this helps strengthen and develop the
team as well improving the culture
without that culture teams can stagnate
without that culture groups of
high-performing individuals may never
cohere into a high performing team
but differently software expertise
doesn't happen by accident
there are practices that you can
understand and invest in by making space
in your organizational culture and by
investing time for this mindset these
sorts of practices these dialogues
you're making space for expertise to
work and grow and for expert level
software development to become possible
thank you for listening I hope that you
this has given you a chance to an
opportunity to reflect on your practice
and that there have been some resonances
for you and again if you have comments
or examples I would love to hear from
you
okay one good question to get started I
guess many of us are now getting into a
mode where we're working remotely
working from home and a lot of what you
talked about was very much about culture
and like social uh I guess phenomenon
that you know people can use to
to work through these errors how does
working from home and working remotely
affect the things that you've been
discussing
um I think anybody who's been working
just from home knows the costs by now
and the costs come in terms
typically of some of the informal
interactions that people have rather
than the formal ones
so the teams that work remotely and do
it effectively have a couple of
ingredients one is they know each other
one way or another either because they
spend enough time one-on-one dialogue
online or because they've met face to
face
um and they also work on the channels
that they have for in
impromptu conversations so
um
I know a lot of people use slack that
works for some people but others just
make sure that you can you can drop a
message and make a call can I have a
minute so that can I have a minute is
normal it isn't the kind of intrusion
that it can seem to be online
um one of the things I know for high
performing teams that have an internet
have an international
collection they have distributed teams
they really work at the beginning
to form a shared culture so that they
overcome different
interpretations and and different
um
local norms
so there is this sense of which things
are okay and there are demonstrations of
it and so they do things like they'll
ship people around to other sites to
make them familiar
so that when they interact on online
it's a different thing
um so it is about understanding the
importance of basically the
conversations around the coffee machine
and to find an alternative to that
online and there are ways to do that
I hope that answers your question ish
hi my name is Michael thank you very
much for your talk this morning very
very nice
um you can debend it a couple of times
but I'm wondering if you can go a little
deeper in how the experts on these high
functional teams
Engage The novice to bring them along
faster
is there additional training something
that they did to help the whole team
accelerate
biggest thing that they do is
okay
there are two parts one is the team
culture inherently helps with that but
they're very conscious about pairing
people up so
the pair debugging May well be with the
expert in the novice not because it's
because the expert probably has a really
good way of articulating things probably
has the best knowledge of the code base
probably knows how to make the bridging
that says oh you need to talk to Fred
over there about that one
um but in addition to doing that to help
and provide a kind of safe space for
asking questions
um they then also make sure that
the novices paired up with other people
the estimates for how long it takes for
a novice to integrate properly into a
team and into a code base very
but
they vary from one year to three years I
mean we're not talking about short term
and so there isn't an
expectation that someone will
instantaneously not need any of this
because everybody needs it so part of
what works is the notion that it's okay
to ask
no matter what it's okay to ask
um so one of the things that
distinguishes high performing teams is
really interesting is what they retain
in terms of of indications of
performance are not how many mistakes
you made but how many good ideas you had
right so if you ask good questions it
doesn't matter if you sometimes ask bad
questions or you know what appear to be
silly questions very often silly
questions are actually quite insightful
um and so what you're what happens is
because they value the reaching out the
reaching out happens more and with more
reaching out you get better integration
of people into the team and better
education over time
they also work at what they call
rattling the basket so that rather than
leaving people stuck in roles
they try to use people for what they're
best at but they also try to give them
to move them around to spark them often
oh gosh a few
hi thank you this was really cool and I
have a biology background and this also
made me feel like I should get paid a
lot of money so thank you
um so I really enjoyed this I enjoyed
the approach and most of the engineers
I've worked with also I think really
want to take the more systems focused
and the more like ecological Focus like
you said and we often have a hard time
conveying the value of that to the
people who are setting priorities for
what we're building
and I think we're often asked to justify
taking time to focus on these things
unlike a quarter by quarter here's the
value
[Music]
um and can so can you talk about some
ways that you would convey to your like
product organization here's what you're
going to see in one quarter here's what
you're going to see in two quarters it
doesn't look like features but it has
value
I'm not sure I can answer you directly
but I'll give you an observation which
is that
in the high performing teams there is
typically
the the guru in the corner the expert is
very often the bridge between
his team and
the management
okay and it's typically somebody who can
speak management speak as well as do the
engineering and very often so there is
someone who is and then sometimes in
some places I've seen this split into
two roles where there's the technical
lead who has a very intimate
relationship with the project manager
the Project Lead who who takes that
interface role
those are the people if they if there is
someone who has Authority and who has a
track record for productivity
that's where that argument gets made
because they'll be saying things like
wait and see so there and it shows up
other places because the people who
understand the organizational Dynamics
can work with them so their estimation
is different if the organization demands
something you know something from them
that's unreasonable they will kick back
they won't just accept it
and they're able to articulate
the trade-offs very explicitly to them
you know we can deliver it on time and
it won't do these things or you can give
us the extra n months and it will do
this
make a choice
um pay the consequences
so there's a it's it's
I don't have a simple answer to that one
um but in effect they because they know
the difference between the metrics and
the purpose they very often draw the
dialogues with management back to
purpose albeit framed in ways that I'm
using Management in this pejorative way
I do apologize to people I hope you
understand what I mean
um to to the the people outside the team
um so they they managed to
tie the decisions
to purpose while also translating it
into the the language of the out people
outside the team
hi uh
uh thanks so much for your talk
um I'm curious so
um a lot of the insights you gave about
experts were insights about experts in
the development process
um meaning
an expert I've already hired I'm curious
if if you have any insights into
identifying expertise during the
interview process so that
I can hire those people to then do
things and build this expert team with
so that's a question that comes up I
mean that's a question that I discussed
with Mike Hoy at various points
um
so the thing that
Andre vanderhook my collaborator and I
believe on the basis of all the
empirically grounded insights they're in
the little yellow book
um
is that what you're looking for is a
mindset
so the kinds of things that that
indicate someone is headed toward
expertise has have to do with their
approach to error have to do with their
engagement with diverse problems have to
do with the way they handle dialogues
have to do with whether they look at
Alternatives and maintain Alternatives
whether they understand provisionality
so and it isn't a checklist per se but
what we had talked about previously was
the notion that you could for example
look through the insights in the book
and say do we see some of these
manifests in the conversation not
specific ones but any of them is is
there evidence of the mindset when
somebody comes to talk to you do they
only talk about the solution or do they
talk about the problem and do they talk
about the context in which the problem
resides
so we went to do
um some design videos with people where
they we had two people at a whiteboard
and they responded to a design prompt
and we asked the companies that we went
to to give us some of their good
designers and we the Andre showed up at
one of these and the designer was
surprisingly Young
so they did the video and it was a
terrific design dialogue and afterward
they said to him
how did you get to be what you are
and his response was
while I was studying
I picked every problem I didn't know how
to solve I looked for all the things
that that I wasn't sure about I wasn't
afraid to try things out and start by
failing and then find somebody to help
me out
and he had over the course of his
notionally relatively short career
addressed lots of different things and
then had conversations with lots of
interesting people
and that propensity to that openness of
attitude the mindset that said I need to
understand how to understand problems
before I dive into Solutions
um marked him out and was evident in the
kinds of conversations that he had with
people and that lack of fear
so I think looking for the mindset is
the short answer
awesome thanks so much
hey uh thanks again for the talk I'll
play this is a fun one can you tell us a
little bit about the design inspiration
for the balloon animal illustrations
laughs
um
the design expression so so all of the
illustrations in the little yellow book
and most of the the drawn things that
were in the talk are by a very talented
young illustrator named inquatch
and she has a real net for
listening to a conversation and making
sense of it and providing illustrations
of it
but lots of ideas are much easier to get
over if you have a bit of a giggle with
them
um and so we were looking just for
interesting ways of conveying the
insights without locking them to a
specific example
in the domain when everybody would say
was it that Insight is only connected to
that example and I won't generalize from
it so a bit of play playful is good
awesome thanks okay
hi thank you so you mentioned that
um all software errors are specification
errors and I think a room full of
developers we we'd all agree
um but I was interested in your story
about the social worker application
where the the people who specify the
design of the software were not the
people actually using it and so
I'm interested in uh any observations
you may have about
in particular in a Consulting world or
contract world where you have a specific
client
um how would a software team that's
being effective how would they perhaps
encourage the client to include the
right opinions say when specifying the
software
it's an interesting one I so I'm not a
software developer but I did do
consultancy and interaction design and
there was a company who used of software
developers they would hire me in
to do user studies
because
their management didn't think it was
appropriate so the software Engineers
knew it was and they wanted to do have
more access to their to their customers
so knowing that there are some people
who listen more to people you pay for
them
externally so they brought me in to
provide evidence of something they
already knew
and I went out and I would go study the
the users and present what the user said
and the sales and marketing people go oh
my goodness that is astonishing where
did you get that from
[Music]
um
it's
the companies that I know there is such
a conviction in these teams
that they really need to engage with
users
that it becomes its bottom line for them
that's and if if if the client doesn't
understand that they need it they'll go
do it anyway
um and I think that's what happens and
then there's a demonstration
by outcome
because they've engaged with users
because they've found something that
every other people overlooked
um they then get credibility and once
they have that credibility then they can
dictate terms much more easily in the
future so a lot of the changes that
people make in terms of development
culture come from demonstrations of
efficacy you know they have evidence
that it works
um and sometimes it's because I did this
previously and I can show you the
outcome you know if you want to know how
these guys got their IP let me tell you
and sometimes it's by stealth but it's
it's the best way to convince somebody
is to show them the outcomes
okay thank you
excuse me I think we need to end at this
time
um so we can pull put the walls up for
the next session but thank you so much
thank you everyone